to dust that is a
a manipulator move and it doesn't change
the fact that he's not necessarily
enough that's women want to take to eat
to take the easy way out
men just are homeless
if a man has no opportunity he's just
homeless
where women they get to use that if they
want to and then they take the easy way
out and then like they're not being
manipulated if they make a choice go
ahead i mean
you're saying the easy way out like i'm
not going to sit here and
defend
all the points but it's one thing
so just record it yeah that's all we
keep going it's one thing to say the
easy route but i think there's a there's
an element of survival instinct that
goes in there and it's it's one thing i
think what she's speaking about is not
just like oh i want to be a millionaire
tomorrow
i'll do that it's more of like a
and correct me from wrong it's more of
like uh if i don't do this i'll be
homeless and you're saying men will go
and be homeless and that's fair or
they'll get a job which is fair but i'm
i'm assuming what she's speaking about
is like as opposed to being homeless
this is an option i have that i won't
that's so why yeah so you get an
opportunity yeah and so i'm saying like
how are they being manipulated if you're
being given an opportunity like because
i i kind of think of
from my point of view like i run youtube
channels and so i know how much work
goes behind like making money off of a
youtube channel on the back end so he's
just doing that with only fans work and
so where he knows the back end he knows
what to say he knows how to make money
he knows the business and if the girl
wants to take the opportunity she can or
she can
like like that i kind of do something
similar it's like if you want to go
build it on your own good luck but
compare that to kind of the music
industry and a lot of the how artists
came in like you know usher and all
those were like 17 16 when they started
then eventually they're 18 they signed
this contract and from my perspective
mike's becksburg opinion i guess um a
lot of these contracts aren't in their
favor and they don't know that um and so
in those situations it's one thing to
say okay like we didn't manipulate them
they signed this contract
but there is a predatory and i don't
want to use
there's like an element of predatory
nature that goes into that like here's a
contract we drafted it it's in our favor
you'll write one song and sing it and
become famous but we own all your
masters i think it's kind of in that
same vein not i mean well i think it's
just more like than do it on your own
i mean like it's just it's just someone
has lev every deal someone has leverage
there's a million people that want to be
famous there's only a couple music
companies so if you have leverage you
get a better deal so now the question is
yes it's a leverage thing the people who
take advantage of that leverage to like
an extreme
point are they not bad people and the
people who
have less leverage and
and who have less leverage and are taken
advantage of or they like they're not
well i don't think it's i think it's you
take what you're worth
so
if you could get a better deal elsewhere
you wouldn't take it that's true
otherwise go go somewhere else go start
it on your own they don't want to do
that
i was going to say would you have the
same idea if a lady suggested to do it
on her own so she's out there doing not
knowing she's tricking finessing
whatever you call it is that good
business or is that manipulation well i
have my own opinions on all that of the
whole system and that whole
well but um i think if she does it on
her own that's that's one thing but it's
it's another thing to like i can
appreciate that there are people in
hard situations where it's like here is
an opportunity and you will take that
opportunity more so than anyone else
like the average person and those are
quote unquote vulnerable people that'll
do xyz so and they don't think they're
vulnerable i think they're lazy
you could talk to men on the internet
and take your clothes off or you could
go work at mcdonald's and they said um
i'll give you an example i'll give you
an example let's let's use it in a more
professional setting let's say you you
know you went to school spent hundreds
of thousand dollars to get a degree
and now you have debt and now you have
to take like you know you apply for jobs
the one job that gives you an
opportunity is a job that pays pretty
trash
and you know they have some very like
you know the terms aren't amazing but
it's the only job you got you have debt
and if you don't do that your options
are to be homeless or to take this job
i think you
would agree with me if i if you said
um if someone said like
you know i'm not gonna take that job i'm
just going to go be homeless you look at
that person and be like no you're being
lazy take the job do
would you agree with me on that because
in the same vein
if that person takes the job and now
they're in a you know a shitty place a
shitty deal i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't
i wouldn't call them
lazy if they chose not to take an only
fan's job
if they chose so because i think that's
the comparison you're trying to make but
i i would say just don't like there are
consequences for every decision i
wouldn't say you're being manipulated
but i mean like things can be right you
can be manipulated how are you being
manipulated if you you really chose to
take a job i i think manipulation has a
negative context but it's not it doesn't
necessarily have to be like if i walk
into the room and i'm wearing like a
cologne and everyone likes the cologne
and i'm like oh by the way buy this
cologne
that's a manipulation in a sense it
doesn't have to be like uh it's
advertising but baptizing his
manipulation you're manipulating he's
right
we see it in a negative context but it
doesn't have to be i think manipulation
well i'm talking about how she was
describing it it seemed negative
like because we're kind of like
changing the goal post a little bit go
ahead
i'm going someone who was speaking with
me
oh sorry i thought one of you were
saying something i was you um
i wanted to respond to that if if you
choose to go into sex work
understand that there are certain
consequences that you have to deal with
but like andrew tate said he likes to be
in romania because he can pay off the
police which makes you ask why would you
want to pay off the police if everything
you're doing is legit and it's like with
the stories of these girls comparing it
like saying how it's so hard to leave
because he even scares these girls into
not leaving and uses his power and fame
against these girls what are these girls
in romania gonna do do you have like
what clip are you talking about because
we could pull it up um basically i just
like watching how some people just
gather up their research and collective
there's a let me oh i can just yeah
it's fine you can you can grab your
phone
um and then blessing can pull it up or
if you um if you send it to me on
instagram i'll put it in the dark so
blessing can use it is that the one
where he was he mentioned about um it's
like the grape associated one where he's
like oh i'm not saying i'm a rapist but
i like to be in countries where i can do
whatever i want is that yeah that's the
that's the snippet of him but in terms
of the people who've released this
information about um andrew tate but
then again it could be false so i'm just
saying that
usually like i mean if you think about
the statement and then the allegations i
just think there's there has to be some
sort of connection but then again
i just think like you have to be proven
guilty of something
like i don't i don't like being in a
society where we can like you can be
proven guilty without going to court i
agree with that to a certain extent you
know that i think it's so much better if
you can have substantial evidence behind
something before you can make those
accusations i think what's very
problematic about this case is that
there's a lot of
smoke
so you have to kind of question is there
a fire behind it if there's multiple
clips coming out with multiple
allegations and multiple like yes we
made a point about like click bait and
you know certain things might be said
for entertainment purposes but when
there's that much smoke i'm a bit
curious well i don't know because one of
the so i was doing the interviews and
one of the common things that people
were saying is there was that clip of
that girl getting like
um
they said she was being abused on camera
um but then she came forward and said
nah that was a yeah you know that was a
sex play that's actually one of the
clips i have for us to watch but then i
guess the same the same uh thing that we
would apply to is that true or not you
could say the same thing for her it's
true because there is feeling
manipulated does she have to retract it
because just as she was saying before
when someone's a massive superpower has
a lot of money and a lot of influence
behind them
people retract their statements a lot
when there's such things as saying
really i'd say they're more i would say
girls come out more when someone has
power money and fame i mean how many
girls have come forward and had great
accusations against men just to be
proven they're lying because they
empower money and fame yeah and how many
girls have never even come forward at
all because they're so petrified i mean
i would i wouldn't go that far because
there has to be evidence
there's not evidence if you won't go to
court and press charges yeah you can't
say there's there's you can't say so you
can't say oh there's all these girls
that don't come forward if we don't have
evidence yeah you're just you're just
like assuming you're assuming they're
telling the truth no you make a really
good point there that there isn't
evidence in court but that doesn't mean
there's no evidence of their experience
exactly but you have to investigate you
have to investigate claims and so even
even in this case like i think
oftentimes like we have this default
where we want to defend women at all
costs and you're kind of doing it
because even when she says the words out
of my mouth are um i
this was a sex play this was just play
you're still trying to like paint him as
the bad guy no it's interesting because
you said i'm trying to defend women at
all costs and this particular case is
pertaining to women if it was to do with
a man my stance would be exactly the
same and i think there's something to be
said as well there's physical abuse but
we can't forget there is mental abuse
and that's something that does happen
and you have to remember that yes
although some women have consented in
that moment but there is a big element
of mental abuse that does happen to men
and women and i do think again what is
mental abuse mental abuse comes in i'm
not going to go but in order to accuse
someone of something you have to i
didn't i didn't say specifically
agitated i'm saying in general i'm
saying in general in order to talk about
this like we have to have a definition
100 but i would say mental abuse comes
in all shapes or forms that's
manipulation that's control it's right
across the border however you want to
see it but what i would say
is that you know especially women you
know you have really strong women like
we would say us through here very strong
women however things that we may not
tolerate or we may stand up to another
woman won't do that everyone's an
individual everyone's different but we
can't sit there and say just because you
retract your statement or you consent or
you say okay actually this is what
happened i've changed my mind we can't
sit there and say we don't believe you
because mental abuse does exist a
hundred percent i'm saying we need
evidence
to go to court before we make an
assumption about someone but how many
times in court like have you
seen there's been a case and it's been
like okay the evidence has shown the
person's not guilty but really and truly
the person probably is guilty let's be
honest i mean but you have to be offered
evidence i mean i don't know
it's like this it's it's
especially when you kind of see grape
cases exactly there's not a lot of
evidence that's why a lot of people get
let off and x y and z and people retract
statements so i think it's hard to say
oh let's go to court because you don't
always have that evidence to to back up
what you're saying is true or confidence
as well someone may or may not be
confident enough and as well some women
are embarrassed they feel like you know
i don't want to put all my business out
there in court for everyone to know
what's going on i don't want my business
in the media or for everyone to come up
to me and say xyz and especially if
someone is you know of a certain status
and has certain financial backgrounds
they're thinking i'm scared i don't want
that person to come for me now so they
may retract their statement so
personally speaking like i said before
mental abuse does exist and i think
you know we can't sit there and you
can't define it i can't define it okay
what would you do that's not well that's
i i don't want to define it i mean it
comes in so many shapes and forms i
don't have to define it but you you but
i'm saying you do if you're going to
talk about it but i think anyone
mentally i think comes in a lot of words
and forms and you don't you can't
i can
do you know what it is no because the
problem is like the problem is when we
make these broad definitions it like you
you're accusing men of things i didn't
kiss anyone no but when you're when
you're you're saying mental abuse is
real
okay
and you're you're saying that mental
abuse is real and all of these things
happen and it's painting a picture of
men and when you don't define what it is
because even sexual assault and grape
like we don't even have a clear
definition of what those are i'm so
interested about how good no i'm just
really interested how um again in that
statement i mean we were we started off
about you know
what is abuse yeah kind of coming from
that from that point um and you
immediately said that we're painting a
certain picture about men
about you
because we actually grape grape is grape
whether it's men or women men or women
back to your point around what is mental
abuse and i think
um you know nelly makes a really good
point about it's very hard to define
mental abuse
um
and i think the reasons why is there's
many different tactics that involve
mental abuse for example
control of finances could be a form of
mental abuse gaslighting so oh you think
this happened no it didn't i'm pretty
sure it did let's run the tapes there
aren't always tapes in life we can't we
can rewind this video we can't do that
it's just a liar
okay so is lying not abuse no i don't
think that's abuse why not i i wouldn't
i would define abuse um how would you
define lying what lying not telling the
truth i mean the average person lies
three times a day so i don't think
everyone's abusive in this in the
context of relationships um yeah in
relationships average person the average
person who who are you lying to people
that you have relationships with okay
yeah but in in the context of one person
has more power than the other as a
result of telling that lie if you're in
a relationship when someone decides who
defines who has more power that's part
of the question that's what i'm laughing
and this is part of the defining thing
i'm saying i don't i don't think that
lying is mental abuse i think that's a
stretch
okay okay so that's your definition you
see how you see how everyone has
happened
i don't
i i think mental abuse i i don't really
know what it is because women use the
terms
no i'm saying it's i don't use the term
like in general i don't talk about it
but i'm saying women use that term so
broadly that i think it's lost the
definition i don't even know what it is
i was going to say ladies
say my suggested to you when's the
difference between good business and
manipulation because let's say you work
in a nine-to-five job and your manager
suggests if you don't do a task properly
you're gonna be in trouble so would you
agree that's some form of mental abuse
or does that not make the
the sort because that causes a lot of
stress that can put someone in a certain
way but as soon as we um
come away from the work aspect and it
comes a bit more personal why do the why
do things change in that respect i think
everyone has a motive like you can kind
of throw
with the work example you just had if
you're working in nine to five and if
you haven't done your work which is like
in your contract and there's naturally
there's gonna be backlash because you're
being paid to work if you're taking that
same stance for
being at home for example and it's like
your husband or wife said oh if i come
home and the washing up isn't done then
there's going to be consequences but
it's the same concept i'm saying your
manager's saying to you before you even
started the task if you don't do this
you could possibly be fired so is that
not a form of abuse
i think i think i think we obviously
again this is the lovely thing about
having these debates because there's
different definitions right for me
personally i think if it's at the
detriment to someone's human dignity
yeah that's abuse
so dignity is in life then what is your
is your well-being what can't tell me on
the date so yeah i definitely define
that as abuse anyone at work that will
tell me something's going to happen to
me before i've even done it but then we
make it a lot more different when it
comes to relationships and i'm not
saying that that's what you ladies are
fighting for but i just find it
interesting that's what we do as humans
yeah i think humans are super complex
this is why it's a great thing to do
emotional abuse and involves attempts to
frighten control or isolate you
that's what they says online
it's cool so by that definition
everything everyone's kind of said
doesn't fit into it
i wouldn't say lying that would really
fit into it i mean but i mean what's the
line what's the ends
well i think then
and this is why your point about
intention comes up you know
intention what do you mean
so tam was making a point about kind of
like motivation and intention behind
stuff
so i guess
is the lie to
exert a sense of control and power
i think i think it intentions is stupid
because you're never going to know
someone's intentions
you can't you can't mind somebody cares
you can't mind me someone's intentions
right
sometimes some people don't even know
how to come in yeah but i would even i
would argue with you i would say uh
intention does matter like
to say who cares is is not it's not fair
because even like in the law intention
matters like if you slip and fall and
someone dies as a result you didn't
intend to do that you don't go to jail
in the same way that if you plan that so
i think intention matters
figuring that out is a different thing
but it's hard it's i wouldn't agree with
you to say it doesn't matter who cares
yeah i guess because for example let's
say
you're walking and say you're at
carnival um
someone throws a bottle
at you one of us it hits your head and
then you're oh my gosh i'm i'm hurt
right now and they say oh there's no
intention there there's an accident it
doesn't matter i guess does it matter
how do you feel at that point i guess
you're right in the eyes of the law but
like i just think the results matter
yeah like i don't really give a [ __ ]
like okay if somebody hit me with their
car on accident or on purpose i don't
give a [ __ ]
i got hit by a car
yeah because the outcome's the same
exact so you're in the eyes of the law
sure but just personally i'm like i
don't really give a [ __ ] yeah
yeah you've hit the nail on the head
there you've hit the nail on the head
because the outcome is the same which is
pain
but let's try this i like that what you
said so you know let's use that with the
andrew tape situation like if he's
intentionally trying to like mentally or
whatever abuse someone we can say he's
an [ __ ] but if he's just like walking
home and saying like hey like i have
this car this whatever and someone's
you know
persuaded in a certain way and that
might be abuse or whatever i mean he's
not an [ __ ] in that sense i would
just disagree that he mentally abused
anyone he allowed those women to be
millionaires i mean i'm not i'm not even
yeah i'm so curious because this is such
a great conversation
you seem to be like quite a proponent of
some of his viewpoints what is it that
you like about the things that he's
saying
um i think that he
i think a lot of the stuff he says makes
sense like for example he talks about
how men and women are different and they
have different roles i think a lot of
times in society we have women that want
to be men and men that want to be women
and i think it leads to people being
unhappy in the long term and it's a lot
of bad advice
and he just says that men are different
and women are different
i think he says a lot of things that are
true they're uncomfortable like old
women are less desirable women that have
slept around are less desirable but it's
true no dude wants a girl that's been
ran through by the whole football team
they just don't
in general um
unless yeah i mean there's exceptions
but i think like he's at least honest
okay
um and i'll second that he's merely
stating things that most of society
thinks behind closed doors so then to
then point your finger at him and be
like you shouldn't be saying that i
think it's very hypocritical because
there's a lot of influences there
stating their views
i think there's a there's a young lady
that's been compared does anyone know
her name i think she's latina descent
and she's really big on tick-tock and
she's making statements about men left
right and center and no no banning of
any sort has been going on but i think
yes he's he's extreme in how he says it
but this is what people think but you
know sometimes it's
like goes back to the saying it's not
about what you say it's how you say it
and sometimes when your delivery is very
straightforward very aggressive very you
know
straight to the point sometimes it comes
across quite aggressive and people will
just be like just write you off straight
away whereas if your delivery was a bit
different i wonder if andrew tape's
delivery was different if people would
if he would have wouldn't have been
banned on social media and if he would
have taken him differently i think
that's a woman's point of view i think
that's a woman's point of view though
because men communicate differently than
women yeah
it goes back to like women trying to
make men women but they're not they're
men yes and then communicate differently
than women they're more direct they're
more honest typically i mean like how
many times
like i mean i've had so many girls on
this show tell me
that lizzo is like above a five which is
just like crazy like it's lizzie
but every i think yeah everyone's scale
is different at the end of the day what
your five is someone else's yeah someone
is definitely yeah
i think i think objectively like if
you're 300 pounds you're below 5.
that's your opinion though that's your
opinion i mean
that's your opinion but it's based off
of reality which women don't like to
live in because even this is like not
reality and you know it on some level
because you know if you walk into a bar
with lizzo you guys are all going to get
more attention than lizzo like do you
have anything
not necessarily like you're looking for
exceptions it's not the rule you could
take you could take you could take
dating app data where we like let's like
put your profile on lizzo's profile
who's going to get more attention it's
going to be you we could go to into a
modeling a modeling agency and say who
are they going to sign you or lizzo in
general unless you do that victoria's
secret like you know
the new body positivity type [ __ ] i know
again again exceptions but whenever you
go anywhere where there's like an
objective standard of beauty where like
people are find this the most attractive
in general you're you guys are all
prettier than lizzo and that's not
because my question is and i think yeah
you make some again interesting points
around like
it's really helpful to see that like i i
don't know if you guys always see like
the stats that come out from certain
dating apps
to say certain names but they they
produce these stuff right like who comes
out as the most desirable women my
question would be and modeling agencies
and modeling agencies yeah um by who's
beauty standards i was just going to say
that i mean i would say like
collectively society as a whole so if
you survey if you survey if you survey
men and women as well and you if you
survey men and women as a whole in
general in most societies
and
and most societies throughout the world
everywhere ever i guarantee like just
just base that wait let me let me finish
in most societies throughout the world
everywhere if we put a picture of you
guys in a picture of lizzo if you ask
most guys and most girls they would find
you more attractive in west africa and
except yeah they always this is what
this is what girls do like sorry i've
been doing this couple months not you
personally but like like this is what
they'll do they'll bring up the one
exception in that one
society in west africa you're right
there's one society in west africa where
that is the exception
but
everywhere else
that is the rule i think it's such a
eurocentric way of viewing beauty look
at the size of africa let's look at the
size of europe i won't even do all that
i won't even do all that i think what we
can also look at is just beauty
standards shift right like i was 10
years ago having a like a fat ass was
like okay you but nowadays it's like if
you don't have a fat ass you're not
attracted exactly
wait talk talk and you're talking sorry
it stays a while when there's a standard
set so
um let's say 10 years ago being a super
model finn was in fashion it will stay
there for a little bit then come another
trend yeah it's not like it just changes
but but the point i'm making is that
the issue that i'm having is and i agree
with you it's weird i didn't think i was
going to disagree with you as much as
i'm doing today but um
when it comes down to that number of
like or you're five and below it's like
okay
ten years ago if i had a fat ass then
i'm a five and below but i didn't say 10
years ago i said today but i'm just
saying like it shifts so for you to say
like oh like i i'm not gonna comment on
lizzo but for you to say that so
definitively that if you're over this
you're that
i think that's what people have a hard
time dealing with and on top of that
it's like we connect that what's that
five mean
do you think do you think in most of
human history okay one there probably
wasn't even women over 300 pounds in
most of human history but since since
the development of like obesity has
obesity ever been desired by and large
by then
by and large i i can't call it but okay
i don't know come on just with your
common sense
just with your common sense i mean with
my common sense i want to say no but
that's that's
right i don't know what them just by and
large i just think personally speaking
in london in terms of 2022 now what is
considered like a 10 is very different
like we said was five years ago and i'm
not gonna lie being thick which is um
thick comes in all different shapes and
sizes it can go from somebody that is
let's say a size 12 but she's got really
thick fires or a big bum or something
someone that's a size 18. it is
different i would say
i don't personally agree to say someone
that's over 300 pounds
would then be considered
below a five i i don't agree with that
and i think a lot of i'm gonna say
especially in london specifically
i don't think a lot of people are gonna
sit there and say that i mean i mean i
think sometimes like you have a warped
world view because um like the society
is made for women so like 70 to 80 of
consumer buying decisions are made um by
women and so you see the whole media is
tailored towards women so when you see
women in the media it's like pretty much
just to cater to women but the thing is
like the majority of the most desired
women if if they're thicker they have a
small waist it's always been the
hourglass but you get some women that
could be over 300 pounds and have a
small waist that happens have you seen
that i've definitely seen it
no you're right i've been pleasantly
surprised like sometimes you'll ask a
girl
i i wait i weigh more weight i i weigh
more i have a friend that's six five
yeah and we would weigh more than you
would expect exactly but i'm saying it's
three hundred dollars 300 is pushing it
300 through definitely pushing because
yeah i don't know what the engine looks
like on a guy let alone no
but
i mean i always like to count a question
to ask all the ladies in the room
generally speaking would you be more
attracted to a man that's over six foot
or around that region there in
comparison to someone let's say my
height five foot seven
with with a good personality naturally
with your instincts what do you feel
you're selling yourself well i love it
hey listen
i will keep it real
i feel like we should be diplomatic if
we're like you haven't spoken that much
well personally i've never been
interested in height like it doesn't
bother me whether they're the same
height as me taller shorter whatever
like
i am much more of an emotional person
than i am sort of that side of things
that's not what i initially go for it's
like that connection with a person i
don't care whether they're taller than
me or not or whether they've got you
know a dad board or a six-pack like
that aesthetic side of it isn't
important obviously you've got to have
an attraction to somebody to want to be
with them
but i don't think
i would necessarily go for somebody
who's got those norms if they do they do
but that's not what i intentionally look
for mm-hmm
yeah
yeah no i literally yeah did you guys
date a guy three inches shorter than you
yes yeah
who said no me okay at least you're
honest i think i'm just no i haven't i'm
being dead um i would date somebody
who's the same height as me but
personally i would just feel like um
you see if i wear heels i understand
like there is that element but i would
overall like to be with a man that's at
least the same height as me or taller
because it just makes me feel like
i don't know if i think it's more
masculine i'm just attracted to that
personally
um and you had like the best connection
with someone and you honestly were like
this person is my soulmate like i have i
can get on with them better than anyone
else and i generally want to you know
spend the rest of my life with them
whatever but then you go oh actually
there's a few he's a few inches shorter
than me i'm just being realistic because
you see i'm i'm not necessarily like a
man like a visual creature but you know
the first thing you look at is actually
looks so even if let's say you're not my
usual type or there is something about
you that's you know like oh you're not
my perfect type i feel like there needs
to be that sort of attraction and if
there's no attraction between me and
that person i would just see them more
as a friend per se and that's just
me personally
no i do agree with you in that sense
like in terms of your original question
would i date a guy that's your high or
not the same height as me yes i would if
someone was three inches shorter than me
no i wouldn't mainly because i'd like to
wear heels that's just me personally so
i would just feel like i'm just towering
over that person but um yeah to echo and
what you said
it you when you first meet someone it is
that initial attraction and i don't
think if i'm being completely honest i
would be initially attracted to someone
that is three inches shorter than me
especially because i'm actually quite
short in any way but that's just my
personal opinion but i wouldn't i would
date someone i don't have to be six foot
that's not in my
but taller than you at least that would
be ideal but even if you update someone
that's in the exactly same height as me
if you're saying hi to me i think i
think his point is that women generally
like taller men yeah in general can i
can i suggest that
maybe do women like that because it kind
of emphasizes their femininity like
when you're larger than a man you kind
of naturally feel like well maybe i'm
not as feminine as i should be yeah it
just makes you feel a little bit more
petite and
kind of like what you were saying it
does make the man feel a little bit more
masculine and muscular when he's a bit
bigger than you and you just yeah it
just feels feels nicer
but is that they're not the same kind of
thing if i was to say look lizzo is not
my type but yeah her size and majority
of men will think like that is that not
we're not going towards the same kind of
but then i'm not i'm what i'm not
arguing about that i'm saying i wouldn't
necessarily look at lizard and be like
oh just because she's um 300 pounds
she's a [ __ ] she's a 5. i wouldn't
say that
it depends are you just basing that off
weight like what are you basing it off
because if you actually look at lizza
why actually she's a very beautiful
woman when you look at i'll tell you
what i would be you're just basically
yeah i would base it off of if you put
lizzo in front of a hundred people what
they would rate her one to ten most
people would rate her below average and
is that because you're looking at that
based on her size
yeah i mean you're less attractive if
you're fat but then i wouldn't
i see i don't agree with that yeah i i
don't agree with you
i think yeah but that's personal opinion
and a lot of people
will sort of make a judgment on an
initial viewing of somebody so the first
time you see someone or the first time
you speak to someone you jump to a
conclusion and you judge them whether
you mean to or not and you're a
judgmental person or not but then it's
whether you
you know give them give them a chance to
i'm not saying they don't have any
qualities i'm just saying that like
first impressions like you're rating
people by looks like like everyone
everyone
like sort of decides whether they think
they're gonna be i don't know attracted
to somebody friends with somebody on
their first impression some people will
take it further and actually want to get
to know that person other people will
stop at that point and then go no
further and not want to get to know them
i'll be honest with ladies i'm sorry you
have the power in terms of the majority
of the pool so you are choosing you've
always got the choice i'm sorry you're
not giving a guy you don't find
attractive a chance to even get there so
there's no personality test there's no
none of this get to know him because
you've already um you're given access to
who you want to especially if you like
all the ladies in this room you have a
lot more choice than a lot of others so
if a guy's 300 pounds overweight
and you're not into that that it's
unlikely he's even gonna get that chance
so that's why i kind of debunked that
theory of i wouldn't date this or that
because you always got those kind of
choices and if it was true if women
weren't picky about looks one in three
men wouldn't be virgins or haven't had
sex in the last year one out of three
like women are very picky when it comes
to look and some some studies say that
women are more picky about looks than
men 100
i think it's preference i think it's
just your preference and what your type
is some some girls women like bigger men
or men that are not athletic and some
men do like bigger set women it is your
preference some men like short women
some men like brunettes blonde hair just
is your preference would you say we can
get honest data about
what we prefer based on dating apps
i don't use data i mean in general i
couldn't tell you that like i don't know
did you say that like it says something
about by and large because there's
that's the number one way people are
meeting nowadays would you say by and
large we can get some information about
what men and women look for hundred
percent yeah yeah yeah yeah
so so women only swipe right between
five to fifteen percent of the time
where men swipe right fifty percent
so so women are much more selective and
picky than men
i don't know i don't think that's
because it's not
it's hard for you guys to articulate it
because you don't you wouldn't ever go
there and describe it you just wouldn't
is that also because men and women are
using dating apps to look for different
things personally i have never been on a
dating app i've been in two long-term
relationships since i've sort of you
know been old enough to be in serious
relationships whatever i've never dated
around i've never
been on a dating app at all i've seen it
on my friend's phones but that's it so i
don't know whether men and women are
using it for different things are men
just using it to get laid and are women
using it because it's a normal thing to
find people now are they using that to
you know look for a long-term
relationship
why they're being more picky all i can
look at is the results that's the number
one way people are meeting for long-term
relationships too
i just wanted to i'm sure i'm sure
short-term too i'm sure they
i'm sure i mean when when dating apps
first came about that was kind of the
main thing that i was under the
impression
so like tinder yeah yeah
i think you make a good point though
like you that i would agree with that
that
the the intention of why they're on the
app changes things because if you're
looking to date someone for something
important or like long term yeah then
i'm not swiping on 70 people like i'm
making very concerted decisions but if
i'm just looking for like oh what's
happening tonight swipe on everybody and
see who responds right but then to that
what i will say as well that i would say
women are more likely to go on dating
apps looking for a potential partner
whereas men i think they're a bit more
kind of go with the flow and you know
see if a connection comes it comes if
it's just a hookup it's just the hookup
so that could be also why they're
scrolling more freely than women i would
say that's just the men you see
because like women don't see no women
don't like you don't know it but like
women don't see a large like proportion
of men in general like like the men you
want
like they they basically have their pick
of the litter so they don't want to
settle down they're only there for the
short term but like you think the one
out of three men that are virgins or
haven't had sex in the last year don't
want a girlfriend
well i'm sure that virgin could probably
have settled down if you want it yeah it
could probably find someone
again that's a very feminine point of
view because in your life like you've
always had access to sex that's easy but
men have to work to get sex they have to
become something to get sex i don't
think it would be a man's choice to not
have sex for a year
like
bottom line like
he might have values and i think they
could be waiting for the bright women
there might be so many different things
tied up by i mean
if a guy really wanted to just go out
and hook up with a girl depending on
where where obviously you go i'm sure
i'm positive there would be someone that
would be home with that man you have to
keep in mind even guys like drake get
rejected like aggressively so there's no
like
it's it's unfortunate but there are
people who
don't get any attention any play and
it just doesn't happen forever brother i
have to say like the majority of men
have to fight for that any attention
women get attention automatically men
have to go out even if you're attractive
in the top five percent you still have
to work out 100 i think there's this
rejection on both sides yeah yeah
i think you're talking about rejections
if it's exclusive just to me i think
women do get rejected let's talk about
the club the club front like just
standing around socializing
there is no rejection going on for any
woman yeah there is i guess i guess i
guess yeah
i understand
i guess if we're thinking about it in
the context of okay club scenes
by enlarge talking stats again because
we like stocks that's here um men
approaching women right
is it not a form of rejection if a woman
doesn't get approached by a man if
that's the standard way of doing it it's
not a form of because the man has to go
towards it's like going to hunt for
something if i don't hunt that prize
what have i won yeah but don't you think
and what she wants
if she's not
okay um if they did an experiment where
a woman went up to a hundred feet
they did an experiment where a woman
went up to 100 men and asked for sex
and a man went up to 100 women and asked
if they wanted to have sex
um it was around i want to say like 50
of men said yes
where
two
i think one two women maybe said yes out
of a hundred i think that goes back to
like the point that i was trying to make
like a man it's not going to be his
choice to not have sex with yeah because
you know one of the things that men are
built for is to procreate and you know
like
that includes having sex they want to do
that all the time from you know that
moment that they hit puberty regardless
of who it's with that's what they want
to do so they're going to say yes and
flip the question around if it was 100
women asking man to be married like i
think you'd get kind of a similar
similar result like i don't think guys
are jumping for marriage one out of
three i think one out of three would say
hell yeah
like i'm sorry to say it's comparable
the rate women face rejection
you cut but you're comparing it so so
you're implying that it is but i'm just
emphasizing the whole like their
difference like i think guys are skewed
more towards like i would rather have
sex than be married right skew towards
i don't know if that was a comparison
but i see your point yeah thank you yeah
but women women only women only get
rejection out of like from the top 20
percent of guys they just don't want to
go to the bottom 80.
that's
and even coming back on our point that
our debate i just thought about it you
had a mind-blowing moment
a minute but even that factor if that's
rejection that's a beautiful rejection
oh someone didn't come up to me but
every majority of women do get
approached so it's still
better odds in in comparison to men i
was still just i was entertaining the
fact that if that's how if that's the
context we're talking about because you
spoke about a club scene right yeah i
guess rejection can come in many
different ways
i was just using that example because
you set it i mean if i if i got that
form of rejection i'd be quite happy
like okay no one actually told me no but
no one didn't approach me i'd still be
hurt i'd still be there especially if
i'm going to club with all my boys and
all my voices are getting approached and
i'm not getting approached and i'm like
ah but let's be honest i know my ideas
are approaching men like that it's true
it's not massive yeah it's just not
gonna happen yeah but i wouldn't take it
as a badge of honor like oh yeah wait
hold on sorry should i say something are
you saying that like um that women don't
talking just to just approach men well
of course nowadays because not
impossible exceptions to the rules quite
high now i find a lot of women not me
specifically but i'm saying i find quite
a lot of women nowadays you'll be out
and they're very keen to approach a man
okay what clubs are you talking about
because i'll take it he's trying to get
him yeah i'll go no not even clubs i
mean just like bars and stuff like just
being out and jimmy being out again
small percentage of men that get that
very very small percentage are good
looking enough that women will approach
them by and large
there are there are some men like i i
know a couple guys that get approached
on a regular basis
but
yeah they're top they're very very
good-looking guys some might say i do
think yeah
um speaking speaking of top g um we are
gonna react to one of his clips
um that people had a problem with i
wanna see
what who here has a problem with it and
who does it
uh
yeah
i love the the new dating thing is uh do
you like andrew tate if so don't swipe
on me
bro that was trump four years ago
crazy i feel like that's going to be a
lot of dating like pro 15 and 19 year
olds are more attractive than 25 year
olds because they've been through less
dig i'll say this right here on the
[ __ ] internet i don't give a [ __ ]
people will sit there and go you can't
say that yes i can a 19 year old is more
attractive than a 26 year old woman and
i'll tell you why because that 26 year
old has talked to more guys been to the
club more times been more places been
[ __ ] and dumped more times more
arguments more heartbreak more [ __ ]
more mess for me to clean up whereas a
19 year old might have had one guy from
high school just broke up she's fresh
and i could [ __ ] put my imprint on
her make her a good person and without
her having to go through all that
detriment to learn about life the reason
18 and 19 year olds are more attractive
than 25 year olds is because they've
been through less dig i'll say this
right here on the [ __ ] internet i
don't give a [ __ ] people sit there and
go you can't say that yes i can a 19
year old is more attractive than oh
there you go thank you
um
let's go around give you
is this based on like how old is andrew
take like 35
roughly i think roughly you know what i
personally like if basically this is
covering like the age gap type of topic
i personally don't think that
it comes to intentions
now this is a big part of it like some
people come to talk to younger female
because it's easier to kind of get
something out of them because there is
that sense of them being naive because
they're kind of new to the world but i
also don't think it's a bad thing
because i feel like
a lot of
you know girls want stability and like a
serious relationship and the likelihood
of a guy around the same age as you
wanting that is very unlikely
realistically and i feel like older men
who have already experienced it and
almost like kind of had their fun who
are actually looking to settle down are
more likely to give you
what you want so
if it's coming from a perspective where
it's not a form of just trying to like
take an advantage of someone being young
then i don't see the problem with it
okay so you don't have a problem with
what he said like he prefers younger
girls because they've slept with less
people and by and large
you see
now if you see how he's worded it out i
feel like like he's like everyone said
the delivery i feel like it's a bit of
clickbait and it's exaggerated
it is a bit um
i mean there's nothing wrong to want to
be with somebody who slept with less
people like i think that's a that's a
valid reason so
you know i can't really speak against on
i don't think he said anything wrong
specifically here okay here we go
this is like andrew we want to love you
so bad
the thing he does is like he'll say
everything for me was fine until he did
the empress of the imprint thing and i
think that's what a lot of people
latched on to where it's like
okay the 18 19 year old
that's a whatever thing but when you say
imprint it almost sounds very predatory
so like i
generally agree with what he's saying
less people you've been with the less
complications like everyone has baggage
but we're trying to eliminate that
i agree with it but when he says the
imprint thing then i see the world go
crazy and i get it so
i want to be on his side on this one but
that one yeah what's wrong with imprint
i think it just has a negative
connotation of like grooming and like
you know how it was
i think i think of twilight
yes yes
that was kind of fun
so i mean i think that's just like if if
we have no issue with grooming then that
wouldn't be a problem but people
generally have an issue with grooming
so i don't understand how imprint and
grooming because when i when i think of
maybe i just think of the term different
i just think of imprint as like the guy
that made the most of like an impact
that you saw like because i think of
like when the term in the manosphere is
alpha widow
and so like that's what i think of when
i think of imprint and that's like
that's the ambiguity of it like yeah you
can think that way and that's that's how
i thought of it first but then i've
heard people speak about it and like i
hear i can see where they're coming from
what do they think it is they're seeing
it as a grooming fashion like it's like
when you say imprint it's like i want to
like this is this is my girl like she
likes this because i've told her like
this like it's like i'm imprinting
whatever right and
couldn't you do that at like 22 too you
could but it just goes back to the
predatory nature of like someone who's
18. like if you said i want to date a 30
year old because i can put my imprint i
don't think anyone will be crazy about
it but he says like 18 which is already
young and it has all that connotation so
i just think that's why people have an
issue with it but for me everything you
set up to that like makes logical sense
to me but okay
why don't you go next thank you um i
don't think like he's he's obviously not
actually saying oh i'm going to go out
and date an 18 or 19 year old he has
made a very good point that you know the
majority of younger people haven't slept
with as many people but i know when when
you're that sort of age or you're like
school leaver age
all people talk about is how many people
you've slept with all of this and it's
the bigger the number though is the
better when you get older you realize
actually it's the opposite the lower
number of people is better like and i
know that for example i know i'm an
exception because i've been with two
people and i'm 24. and i know that a lot
of people my age would not be like that
and obviously that that's fine and
that's their choices but
i don't think he's saying anything
negative that age gap isn't necessarily
a problem
and the word imprint i again like i
would say my partner has had an imprint
on me because he's
impacted me as a person i don't think
that that is a negative way i think it's
his persona and the way that he portrays
himself and because he is looking for
that sort of entertainment factor and
more views he's going to try and come
across as a bit more of an [ __ ]
because more people are going to talk
about him
okay
and then you and then you guys can go
again yeah although what he says comes
across extreme is again generally what
people think but behind closed doors so
it's taboo only on that basis people
don't speak their mind because they have
to be politically correct so i feel what
he's stating here is that a man of his
caliber
wants to have an imprint not owning or
anything degradatory of that sense but
he wants to let a late a woman know what
he's like like for example um i was
dating a woman who had
she she made her order from boohoo sorry
if i can say that and this dress was
tight
it was tight it was tight to the breast
tight to the booty and we're going on
holiday together and i said straight
away look i'm not trying to control what
you do you've got a choice but honestly
i wouldn't feel comfortable if you're
wearing that because you're walking with
me and i respect you and i feel that
will be a little bit of a disrespect to
me so i i was a bit marginal how i
presented that i wouldn't be like
agitate stating things but
i do understand his concept that he's
preaching on those kind of bases but
he's just being extreme about it but is
there a difference between an impact and
an imprint
i think words matter like if you're
going to say i i want someone i can make
an impact on she's an imprint
i think there's a difference like one
sexual one's not like my dad can have an
impact on me
but i would i feel like if i said
imprint that'd be weird
on something like a cow so that is
an ownership so that's like
you do as i say but an impact that can
be positive like on your mindset i'd
like to think of it as that yeah if he
said impact i don't think that would
have had an issue
do you agree with the imprint part or
not i'm honestly i i still do because i
i like to think i'm a positive person so
if i imprint you of me being positive
there's nothing it depends on your
intention if we want to go back to that
again
even though you just compared it to
branding a cow
that's it that's if it's negative but if
i brand you as a cow and it's positive
and from that moment onwards you're like
oh i like that stamp i got from him i
love being a friend girl
so i'll imprint as many people as i can
but i understand terminology is
important but i feel like we as a
society we look at things so detailed we
lose the point of what we're actually
trying to make he's like oh no that's
too negative to say that and then we
just focus on those things as opposed to
the whole message
i think with andrew tate as well like
he's everywhere in the media and
everyone is trying to find more negative
things about him at the moment so
they're picking out that one word just
on that clip just because they want to
try and make it more horrendous well and
you seem more horrendous and the thing
is is someone like i talk on the
internet people can clip something and
take you out of context
and you'll be in like a two-hour
interview and they take a 15-second clip
they don't watch the full interview and
then they make an assumption about what
you said but in the interview you give a
lot more context and clarification and
where a majority of his clips came on
tick tock yeah they're clips like
they're not the full interview right and
what do you guys think go ahead
me personally when i watch that clip
it's
i personally it does sound manipulating
it really does i don't know how old
andrew tate is but i'm guessing in these
30s for me 40s for me personally what
would a man in his 40s want with a 19
year old
everyone said he's like 40. i'm just
going to 30s or 40 my personal opinion
what would a man in his 30s or 40s want
with five 35
what would a man who's 35 want with a 19
year old and i just think it just stems
from sex that's that's literally what it
is and i just think with the word
imprint you're saying and i do i
personally do associate the word imprint
to grooming as well for me i'm seeing
that as oh you want this 19 year old
because it's like fresh meat you think
no one's touched her touched her she's
very innocent so you can come in have
that imprint and i think at 19 you're
still very young you're an adult but i
think you're still very young minded in
terms of what me now as a 26 year old
when i look back to 19 i look at some of
the decisions i've made i would think if
i had the mindset as a 26 year old as i
am now i probably wouldn't have made
those same decisions because you're a
lot more impressionable so i think
that's what he's coming the sex angle
but then also he can leave his mark he
can be impressionable he can that 19
year old is probably quite naive and new
to the world so he can have his mark and
and make her do what he wants to do i
think men prefer that they don't why
would they want a girl that's stuck in
her ways not necessarily stuck in your
way i think a relationship is about
compromising and i think that's when
if you if that's what you want that's
when the power power trip comes involved
and you know and and that sort of sense
so i think it is kind of manipulation to
a certain extent for me personally i
just think at 30 what you want at 35
compared to what you want at 19
are two completely different things i
think i just think life's about choices
and trade-offs and if you choose to get
it with a guy on that level like you're
kind of on his platform it's not like
power and manipulation if you make that
choice yeah but i think because you can
you can get a guy who like there's so
many sims god
god there's so many you can you could
have a sim that lets you do whatever you
want and but if you want a guy that's
worth something and that's in that
percentage of guys like you have to get
on this program and those men prefer
women that are impressionable i don't
think that's a bad thing but i think at
19 i think a lot of it
is probably materialistic what you what
you want from a guy in terms of oh my
gosh at 19 oh he has money he drives a
car
you're looking at the material things
whereas when you're a bit older you're
not looking at the material things
you're looking at the kind of you know
what what can we build together and i
think at 19 for to go for a man who's 35
years old it's kind of like what you
said the men's looking for sex and the
woman's looking for for money and that
security and the materialistic things is
that a genuine relationship in my
personal opinion i don't think it is in
the west i would agree with you that's
true like women at that age but like if
you go to more traditional countries
like girls at a younger age
are more likely to i don't know
they just they look for different things
it's really interesting to talk to
people from like muslim cultures where
they just get married a lot younger and
they look for like the family 100 but i
even think even in the western culture
if we go back 30 40 years a lot of our
parents and grandparents they were
probably were married and um had babies
at the age of 19. but then it's funny
because when you speak to them now they
say oh my gosh if i could go back i
would have waited i probably would have
had you know a bit more time to kind of
you know see what i really wanted
because at 19 you are so impressionable
and and you are naive you think you know
what you want but do you really really
my my grandparents like they never said
anything like that to me like they would
have waited like they just had a ton of
kids and they're happy yeah i think they
got to feel not saying everyone's
unhappy the odds of you are probably
happy and it's worked out amazing but
for some people they could still even be
in those happy relations but i feel like
they've missed out on an element of
their life where now they're looking at
women
are um in like that who are 19 to even
29 these days and you know they're
living their life they're doing what
they want to do and i think you know
from not everyone but from a couple of
people that i've spoke to from the older
generation they do feel like they've
missed out on that element would you say
that would you say we have a better now
um i think there's pros and cons to now
i think um the pros being you know you
don't there's not there's still pressure
but there's not as much pressure i feel
like if you was to get married and have
a baby at 35 no one would blink twice
whereas if you was to do that
20 years ago everyone would be like
what's going on would you would you say
we should learn from them because the
results were better
and
if they if they had better outcomes i
think there's elements yeah definitely
yeah
like 50 50 of women that hit 30 are
single and childless and the least happy
demographic of women is women over the
age of 40
that make between 50 and 75 000 per year
so that are like career women
i think yeah i think you have a point
there about um
elements of learning from older
generations for sure i think going back
to the whole like andrew tate clip and
what we were saying there i'd be really
interested to hear from like the guys in
the room like
let's imagine you guys have met the love
of your life right you get married
you've been with her for years
you have a son
son is like minnie you you're super
proud of him you have a daughter she's
apple of your eyes she's like daddy's
girl wrap around your finger right
you've raised them all in the right way
in terms of values blah blah blah she
comes home she's 19 and she says dad
i've met someone who is 35 39 and i
really want to be with him because he
says that i'm young and i'm
impressionable and he wants to have an
imprint on me
how would you feel
oh you're throwing it like that you must
have it in front of me i mean
can i ask you a question can they ask or
can i just ask you is he trying to marry
her or date her
we don't know okay we don't know it's
just started then yeah we don't know no
i mean
the time they've met it's just the
beginning again we don't know oh we
don't know they could have been going in
interpret as you as you wish i mean as a
man gen even like for who my sister
would be with generally i get a gist you
talk you communicate to the person
because i was going to intervene and
come back to what you were saying and
say if i was an older man going for
personally i wouldn't go that long i've
got a rule like i don't go five years
below i don't know if i'm right or wrong
for that but
if i had intentions of showing them how
good life could be
let's forget the sex element sex is
always going to come if you're with the
opposite sex you're most likely going to
do it but what if i was showing her from
18 19 you can start thinking about
finances you don't have to follow your
friends who are going to run around and
get
sorry quite unquote ran through
but you could start thinking about
things ahead of time why does it always
have to be in a negative connotation
i could be giving her all of these life
skills yeah early and even if we split
up she's got that for life
yeah 100 in that sense but then it's
still like are you getting what you want
out of that of course i mean i'll get
that
i mean he would get that regardless the
top g the top five ten percent of men if
you're a high value man you're going to
get that because the choices go from any
range you want okay so you're happy for
your daughter at this stage what do you
do
[Laughter]
no i mean i agree with that i think as a
father i would hopefully be able to
assess like intention and i could be
wrong but if he's like a genuinely nice
guy and a good person and all that stuff
then i wouldn't see anything
particularly wrong with it though i
always have i've always had a problem
with age gaps
i've fallen into my own situations where
i was way older sort of thing it's
always kind of bothered me but i think
for the sake of your question if i was
just a father and like my 19 year old
daughter was like i'm dating this 35
year old guy and he comes into the house
and he's just a genuinely good person
and everything you described i have no
problem with it but you know even with
the comment that she mentioned he's
talking like amputee
he's talking like yeah that that was the
question that was the question it's
andrew tate i mean
that your daughter's bought him your
daughter's bought home andrew tate and
these are the clips on tv
as a man you see we again society is
teaching us what's right what's wrong
especially in the last 50 years when
women didn't have as much power so
nowadays we're all being careful i just
told you an example where i asked the
lady i was talking to
can you not um wear that and i'm telling
you it was so difficult because if i go
above and beyond i'm in trouble or i
could be offending her it's so marginal
now so
again
how much power do we have telling our
daughter who and who not to date
do you get what i mean so it's not like
it's that easy what you presented
because we have to look it as a whole
our wife may intervene and be like don't
tell a talker what to do because now
you're embracing sexism so that's where
our society is at it's so it's not that
easy for us to answer these things okay
so may or may not be dating and you take
cool well if i mean i would um as a man
i'll still be like god damn why him of
all people okay if billy down the road
is good andrew
but not andrew can i just check
something you said you fell into a
relationship or into a situation with
with someone younger
how do you
was that just a like a miscommunication
of words how do you fall into a
situation with someone younger i'm
talking well a bit of both so yes and no
the lawyer to me um sometimes you find
yourself in a situation where you start
to connect with someone and despite your
better intention
you have fallen for someone so but if
you've connected with them and you fall
in with someone and if they're not under
the legal age then
then there's no problem what do you mean
like so if if you've fallen into some
sort of relationship or you've fallen
for somebody and you've realized that
they're younger so you personally
do have an issue with the age gap thing
so regardless of the fact you've fallen
for that person no i think for me it's
like and we're talking legal ages first
and foremost before yeah yeah
misconstrued um but i think for me it's
like the elements of the things that i'm
attracted to come with a certain element
of age i'm not talking i'm not trying to
date like someone five years 10 years
older than me but
a 19 year old 18 year old is like it's
kind of like does that joe rogan joke
where he says it just sounds like
they're just learning how to talk
there's that element of like we don't
connect in certain ways but if you run
into someone who
that isn't an issue like if that's not
the feeling you get when you're
interacting with them then you can still
you know that can be pushed to the side
and you can still hang out and if you
develop something and they're genuinely
you know someone you want to be around
all the time then
you know at some point you have to look
at yourself like am i really going to
throw this person i really like away
just because they're 20. well yeah
exactly i think the the comment about
like 18 19 year olds um
like just learning to talk whatever i
think you can have some 18 19 year olds
that have been through a hell of a lot
in their life and you know could be much
more mature than somebody who's 29 30. i
don't think that age necessarily
dictates how mature you are as a person
but they'll always be they'll always be
elements like you can't pretend to be 50
years old when you're not like no so
your experience is limited but your your
maturity and your intelligence isn't
necessarily because some of the most
intelligent people in the world or some
of the most talented musicians might be
children of course
yeah i mean i've met some 50 year olds
that act like they're 15. yeah yeah sure
i'm like some
but then you could even argue he's 35
but he is that he sometimes goes around
acting like he is like 18 19. it's true
but every so often he'll like have a
sober moment and you can see the
maturity cut through and i think there's
there's a limit it's like there's a
ceiling that you have
in general i would say experience
maturity well
you know you know what they say yeah you
know what they say about women as like
they stop maturing as soon as they get
pretty oh
and then they start again once it goes
away
that's savage
fenty
um let's do the next clip blessing
um
actually do do the third clip
can i throw in can we i don't know i've
been seeing the um dicaprio um
oh yeah can we connect that because
everyone's like i look through the
comment section and him you hear he's
got another 22 year old yeah but
everyone's giving him a lot of you know
and i'm like
i i is that in 1822 yeah
but the thing i had a problem with is
that it's like there seems to be this
element of like oh you someone women
only develop their cerebral cortex
whatever 25 and i'm like you say that
but then when you're 18 into the club
you want xy like it just it seems like a
double standard or like i want to have
your kick in either two situations like
i ben knew what i was doing since i was
16. i feel like anything that they're
like oh i didn't know when i was 60 i'm
like um
i wouldn't agree with that fully i just
feel like when i was like i just feel
like it's an excuse like you make
decisions they're definitely things i
would definitely not do again if i could
go back 10 years to seven years but i
think everyone could say that right
regardless of how mature or experienced
they are everyone regrets certain
decisions that they've made yeah so i
wouldn't say i wouldn't say i know my
like even the whole like
you've said on other podcasts you've
always known yourself i think you can
feel that way but if you had a chance
like put yourself in a situation six
years ago i think there are ways you
would look at it and be like
so i mean i think experience like breeds
maturity but i don't i don't think like
i would never take accountability off of
myself and say like blame it on my age
and like i didn't know what i was doing
like i made the decision with the
information i had at the time now i have
more information i'd make a different
decision but it's still my own fault of
course yeah yeah i agree
um i don't make it full screen blessing
if you don't
um
oh this was
that is so funny for me to clean sorry
go ahead god
oh yeah you gotta turn that one off
you can just exit that we're done with
it
okay you do that too
uh if if i were you i'm going to that
argument i could i could rationalize the
argument you just did if most of the
girls that i dated or that i was with
had the iq of somebody who cannot move
think or do anything and it just stuck
on the side of the [ __ ] curb so yeah
i guess maybe you would have this
experience if moses did were zero iq
brain frozen yeah but it doesn't make
sense in the real world because you
don't park your [ __ ] girl on the curb
at the club they move they talk they do
[ __ ] so it's not a [ __ ] it's not it's
not the danger of other guys doing doing
shipping right because they can still
think and the the the
the loss of potent the potential that
that one get out of a million will do
some crazy [ __ ] and and is going to
forcefully bring your home right is for
that smallest is far outweighed by the
fun and enjoyment and fulfillment that
they get
by going the club in the first place
that's interesting but you also have to
understand because we are different
individuals living very different lives
and i'm not going to sit here and
comment on your relationships because i
don't understand them because i don't
know them okay you have to
i am in i am at a status of life or any
woman who gets with me understands
that to be with a man of my caliber
there are certain sacrifices which must
be made you do not get to be with a
kickboxing world champion
multi-millionaire whose entire life is
completely on track and live a life of
spoiled princess and then also say to
that man i go to the club whenever the
[ __ ] i want you might be able to say
that to some other men but you can't say
it to me so a woman which may say to you
i'm a unique special snowflake i do
whatever the [ __ ] i want if she was in
my presence she wouldn't say that now
because women are a reflection of their
man it's not hard to get a woman who
sits there and says you know what i
don't go to the club without my man
because i adore my man if the man
is worthy of such adoration if the
woman's sitting there going well i'm
with him but no he doesn't tell me what
to do that's the man's problem it's
nothing to do with the woman females are
all the same it's all about the man
they're with i have no trouble and no
arguments in my life telling women they
don't go to the club by themselves zero
it's not a conversation that even ever
appears ever because i am me
so for you here and describe scenarios
that's fine and you're saying that my
women are low iq i would counter that by
saying if i was the same women you were
with they'd behave better for me than
they would for you and that is because
of my status and my wisdom and my
individuality
you treat and pay for them like they're
lambos that are parked at the curb of
course they're going to be like this if
you're going to you want to go down that
argument so yeah i i i guess what i have
to concede the point because you're
right i guess you did you dated you did
frozen lambos parked at the curb
that is your example you compare the
behavior and the potentials of her being
stolen to a part lambo therefore i have
to use that analogy when talking about
the girls that you are dating and you
are saying i i i'm sorry it's not an
insult to that you made this precedence
i have to use it
i will take any woman i could date any
of women you've ever i don't know who
your girlfriends are i don't have a clue
but any woman you've ever dated if i was
with her she wouldn't be going to the
club without me that's that's the bottom
line that's because who who i am the
only reason clubs even exist and i'll
tell you why the basic mechanics of
clubs i know a little bit about it
because i own a couple the basic
mechanics of clubs is that you fill them
with girls girls have no money men come
spend ridiculous amounts of money on
alcohol which is massively overpriced to
try and attract females yes if you get
if you get a club with no females in it
no men even go the whole point of a
nightclub you [ __ ] so i will not send my
woman who is with me to the [ __ ]
grounds
can go to okay
i was wondering if she's gonna go to a
place which is specifically designed
three twenty set up for her to get
intoxicated and famous
no my girl can't go out yeah okay let's
let's discuss this this is i
all right cool i take i take my
girlfriends out all the time right cool
but if my girl were to say i want to go
out with seven other girls to the club
in my personal experience i'd be unhappy
for her to do that because i've been the
man in the club that those seven girls
turned up to and end up on this table
and i know what happens i've lived a
very very long life i know how that ends
okay now
now i i think that and i've discussed
this already before i think i discussed
this yesterday with dave portnoy which
he got upset about i just i discussed
that if i'm going to be in a
relationship and i'm going to have
responsibility over a woman which i want
to have because it's my masculine
imperative i should also have a degree
of authority that comes with that
responsibility if i'm responsible for
her safety for example but she refuses
to obey me when i say don't walk home in
the middle of the night then how can i
truly be responsible responsibility and
authority are linked i'm responsible for
her because i'm her man and i take the
best care of her i might take i might
know things she doesn't know she might
be 19 years old and think going to the
club's all fine i'm 35 i've been around
i've seen what happens in clubs no you
don't need to go there i'm responsible
for you i take care of you and by
extension i have authority to say to you
you're not going to that nightclub that
doesn't make me crazy doesn't make me
insecure it doesn't make me weak she can
always say i'm going to go anyway and
that's fine and then we can break up and
any man who sits here and goes i'm not
insecure i'll send my girl to the club
okay send her to my send her to my table
g set her to my table okay no problem
okay
we'll talk about insecurity when you
suck a dick
if your girl was to go to the club right
and i was at the club you're scared that
i will bring your girl home
that i don't live in
it's not about scared because i don't
live in fear well i mean that's that's
fear
no it's not fear okay what it is okay
what is the outcome that you do not want
either her going to the club
i'll
explain guys
guys guys coming over and bringing her
home you by fear you are scared of her
going home another guy that is a move
that is literally fueled by fear you are
fearful
that's an interesting viewpoint and i
know you think that that's relevant and
i know you think you've made a good
point but i'm about to dissect it go
ahead
i'm a territorial individual and i think
that being a man one of the best things
about being a man is being territorial
being able to say that is mine that's
the whole point of it so let's let's use
an analogy and please when i make this
analogy i don't want you to try and get
caught up in the analogy because i'm
about to compare a woman to a car do not
say you're comparing women to cars
that's low iq it's just an analogy if i
go outside right or unless i have a
lamborghini i have many cars but let's
say i take my lamborghini would i park
it in a high crime area even if the
locks are fantastic even if my woman is
loyal and completely and utterly in love
with me and i know there's zero percent
chance any man could ever take her home
because she's with the top g which is
the case even if i know the locks on my
car it has bulletproof glass it's locked
you can't break into it will i park my
lambo in an area where people are going
to try and steal it no i won't because
that is irresponsible
so the fact is i don't care if men
trying to come up to my chick because no
one can steal my chick because i am me
the fact is it's irresponsible for me to
put her in a scenario where people were
attempted if i walk out to the car park
and someone's trying to break into my
car even if the locks to my car are
secure i will still decimate said
individual for attempting to steal my
property
that's what it's about it's about
territorialism it's not about being
fearful the girl is going to run off
with someone else there's nowhere to go
but from me but down about that fair
enough it's a fact that it's
irresponsible for me to put her in that
scenario does that make sense yeah i
mean the argument the argument would be
good if
if i were you i'm making that argument i
could i could rationalize it you just
did you can pause it
okay
yeah okay
so
um what'd you guys think
so the girl lambo
analogies are kind of tricky but again
i wouldn't believe a lady if they don't
find a masculine man attractive
that cares about her doesn't want her in
certain environments
it doesn't act that way every man should
aspire to not want anything taken away
from him especially his lady and i i do
kind of agree
if if i'm in a great relationship why
would my partner want to go to a place
where um sex is at the top of its
ambition in a place of a filled room
people go there for that concept
no matter what people say i'm going to
dance with my girls and
my boys you want attention so that's the
number one thing
and
yeah i just think most people that
disagree with this are not looking at it
from a standpoint view where it could be
positive
guys he's basically saying that he wants
to have a woman that wouldn't want to go
in those environments because she values
him every man should aspire to do that
and that's all i've got to say about it
i think it comes down to preference
again because so he it's his preference
to act territorial and to live his
relationships that way and i do not
believe for one second that one female
has started dating him not knowing that
he's like that they know what they're
getting themselves into so they can't
then complain that he's not letting here
not letting them go out or whatever
because it's their choice to be with him
they know that he's like that not all
men are like that every men have their
own opinions and and differ in how they
treat
like their partner
but you can't tell me that they don't
know that he's gonna be like that
what do you guys think yeah no 100 i
think
if you're gonna date someone like that
you kind of already know their views and
their standpoint so for me you're kind
of signing up to that because you've
made it very clear from the offset um
but do i agree with him no i personally
don't i don't think um clubs are all
about sex some people don't generally do
just want to go out and have a good time
with their friends or whoever they're
going out with and i think personally
when it comes to relationships you
should be allowed to go out and still
live just because you're in a
relationship it's not a prison sentence
you should still be able to go out and
live your life and do what you want to
do i think it comes down to trust like
okay even if i did end up on a guy's
table you should trust in me that
nothing's going to happen in that sense
if anyone does try to approach me i've
got a boyfriend i've got a man that's it
but the girls that i might be with
they're single they're having a good
time whatever i'm just there because you
know i'm with my friends and that's what
it is i think it
all boils down to trust at the end of
the day but i think a vip table yeah no
madam no no that's too personal i don't
think so how's that i don't think that's
personal because look at the
connotations there's like a bunch of
fellows got vip we're the kings and
you've got your woman going to that
section where it's cornered off for what
that was can i just attention you know
with like this whole you going to a club
and a guy picking up girls from clubs
you know you can go to the corner shop
right and a guy that has i don't know
status or money or good looking can
still actually take your girl i mean if
your girl's loyal and you trust each
other it's not going to happen i always
feel like doesn't matter what
environment you're in if you're a loyal
person it's not going to happen i think
also people don't go to the corner shop
to get picked up but
the majority of the majority of people
go to a club to end up with someone but
you can be walking down the street and a
guy's driving past and beeps you that
could be some i don't know some rich
celebrity i don't know who he is it can
happen anywhere that's acceptable
because that's out of our reach but a
vip
can i ask why would okay let's say
you're taken
the reason the majority of the reason
why you're being at vip is because your
girls are single so therefore when you
look at it as a whole you're there
because majority of the reasons people
are single that you're with yeah so then
what happens with you
what kind of message will that be
sending out in any form even if you're
even if you're loyal and you're doing
what you're doing yeah why why are you
there yeah so what i must say sit at
home and wear my pajamas
in the vip
i can't be in vip just because i'm in
the relationship i mean yeah it's
disrespectful i think so with one of her
friends
i personally don't think that's
disrespectful when any guy i don't
because it does for me personally i
think just because you're in the vip you
could still be in the normal part of the
club and still get picked up by a guy
i'll talk to whoever is it it goes back
to your interest your intentions at the
end of the day just flipping what tammy
t said to be fair so let's flip the
script let's say it's you and your boys
on a night out you've got a vip table
let's say you're in a relationship and
let's say all your friends are single
yeah
same thing happens your friend goes out
picks up a load of girls comes on the
table and stuff and you're there you're
not leaving are you i'm checking with
you i i'm precaution would you like i
would even make it worse we're in the
strippers i've already violated
i'm violating as it is i'll check in
with my baby look babes this is what's
going on i don't need any girls snapping
her saying look at him because that's
what happens i just came back from
marbella i saw that live in the flesh
some girl was filming another guy and i
don't know what happened after but how
do you know some girls if let's say they
weren't a vip table let's just say that
was the case
they're not talking to their partner and
saying by the way babe i'm on a table
tonight x y and z let's just say you
have that communication with your
partner and you've let them know that
that's fine what's wrong with that
because because me personally i'm
engaged yeah and a lot of my friends are
single so i've been out and let's say
there is a situation that where that's
happened i speak to my fiance quite
frequently when i'm out so if there is
if there ever is a situation especially
with social media i'm gonna let him know
straight away like this is the situation
so that's right you agree so that's what
i do i'm not saying but then i wouldn't
say
i'm gonna leave my friends and be like
bye i'm engaged so i can't stand there
no it's the fact that
no one can go back and say this is
what's happened because i already told
him yeah but the way i conduct myself
when i'm there
every guy that there knows don't even
bother talk to me
every guy that's there is gonna know do
you know what dove involved with her
again it's all about
the way you kind of come off yeah like
if you're in a relationship with
somebody and you're coming off and
you're it's all about your body language
everyone can read your body language i
think you give off a vibe if you're
i'm
i'm kind of open but i'm not
a man knows that if a woman's very
standoff is just like this don't talk to
me he's not approaching you because he
knows you know what there's just no
point in her leave her alone well what
you said is very acceptable by the way
because i said i'll do the same thing
i'm not going to leave of course but
yeah if i let it if i'm clear about
things i'll show her but the fact is
that's not really happened in that
comment i think we know we know this
we know this people will do things but
ah i'm independent maybe from a woman's
side they're too independent why should
i have to do that and the man's side it
goes without saying that's been
happening from day one
i think definitely
i think the point is you're just putting
yourself in a situation where like it
could be a bad situation where guys are
coming at you and it's just like i when
i'm like i'm single now but when i was
in a relationship i didn't even go to
clubs because i just feel like why would
i want to put myself in that situation
like i can hang out with my friends we
can get lunch we can have girls i think
that shows how different like different
people view how they should be in their
relationship like
andrew tate for example is you know
territorial and that's how he acts in a
relationship some people would feel
comfortable going to a club with their
girlfriends and
you know not paying any attention to
guys whatever
but
personally i've been in a long-term
relationship i wouldn't feel comfortable
going to a club with a load of my single
friends because i know the majority of
the reason they're going to the club is
to try and find men and then what
happens if all of them go home with a
man i'm left on my own out in town
vulnerable on my own whatever
and like i wouldn't find that fun i
wouldn't say because i'm in a long-term
relationship i wouldn't go to a club but
i wouldn't go without my partner because
i don't think i'd enjoy it otherwise
just second and onto what you said
actually about the whole going out of
your friends i think it's your friend's
intention i think you need to know your
friend and i'm not saying you don't
absolutely yeah i'm not coming at you
like that but i think you need to know
your friends i think
to be honest with you if i i wouldn't go
out with a group of girls and their
attention i mean none of my friends are
like that none of my friends i mean i'm
speaking generally yeah like 90 of my
friends are in long term relationships
yeah and that's fine and i'm not and i
wasn't speaking about you directly i'm
just talking about generally speaking
sometimes because we see it you go out
and sometimes girls you see other girls
leave their friends i don't understand
that mindset because for me
me and my circle we're one if we go left
we all go left no one's getting left
home no one's going home with no guys
that's not how we operate so for me i
can go out with single girls to wherever
because we're going out to have a good
time yes if my single friend gets
approached by a guy she might get
approached by a guy they may swap
numbers but the end of the night she's
not leaving me like she's not knowing me
that's your specific friend yeah
your engagement with your partner
whatever and and the trust and the like
the
conversations that you guys have had and
how you know each other but not everyone
is like a hundred percent but that's why
i said i think it depends when we're
saying obviously about girls going out
to clubs if you're in a relationship
single girl i think it depends on who
your single friends are yeah and i think
we can probably all say we've probably
seen situation you're thinking i would
never go out with you because you're
leaving on my own and you'll put me in
the situation
that's what i'm saying i think it really
does depend on your circle and who you
move with definitely yeah i want to add
something um
what andrew tate said was interesting
just about the point where he was
basically explaining like oh i want my
woman to be doing x y and z and you know
i don't want a woman that's gonna
question that and i think
with women i feel like
can men just apply you see i feel like
with men they set expectations and
whether you live up to it you live up to
it if you don't you don't but i feel
like with women women
don't like they have a certain set of
expectation but it's like sometimes you
would get with a guy who like let's say
doesn't necessarily meet your full
criteria but woman will then be like
right but then maybe i can change him in
this sort of element and it's like
when you see
how do i make this without linking back
to the point and it's like andrew women
are complaining like why is andrew t not
laying his girlfriends out no he's just
set himself a standard and that's what
we expect same way as a woman if i want
a man to take me out on a date i would
require you to pay for me but some women
don't and it's like like you said i
think it's a mixture of what you want
from your partner and i do see it like
it can be disrespectful because a club
is really just to socialize me go out
and meet new people but it's like why
are you meeting new men for when you
have like a boyfriend because it's not
on a friendship level let's be realistic
when alcohol is in your system and
i feel like
i'm sorry i understand what you're
saying i i just cause it's not like
you're going there to make pals and the
guys that are approaching you aren't
there to be your friend
and so you're it's like you're putting
yourself in a situation
yeah and it's like with certain friends
like i don't know about me i'm gonna
speak from an experience because i think
that's i'm better at describing certain
situations for experiences and it's like
i can be out with a group of friends and
they all have a motive of meeting and
like new guys and now they've approached
us to go to a table
and
you know these guys when they invite you
to a table they expect something and
it's like even a single friend there by
me going there i still have to put on
some sort of act i need to respond to
you i need to be nice because if i'm a
[ __ ] a lot of the time some guys can
still be like well your friend's not
doing anything and i feel like friends
can peer pressure you friends could be
like well a little bit of flirting is
not going to hurt how many times have
you heard some people be like flirting
is not that deep but the question is now
when i'm flirting with you and there's
alcohol in my system and i'm angry at
you because you've pissed me off this
morning
now what's going to happen now when i
indulge into this conversation and now
i'm feeling like this guy is everything
i've wanted it can actually lead to
cheating how many people go out and
regret after a night out of drinking
that they've cheated on their partner
but wouldn't have done it put yourself
in that situation where you're with
single friends and you're drinking
alcohol which you know
like can
induce that sort of behavior like i
don't i wouldn't put myself in that
situation because
i don't trust other people and you know
anything at people the the like nature
that these days of people's drinks
getting spiked and things like that
there's so much that can happen in those
situations
and i just i don't i don't think
it's a sensible thing to do personally
but obviously you know everyone i agree
and that's the point that i was trying
to make now that i've got it in my head
it's external factors i think andrew's
not worried like he said about people
stealing his girls it's about external
factors you never know what can happen
to you whilst you're in the club and
it's out of your control and it's like
some men find it more safe if they're in
the club because they can watch over
them women and as a man and as masculine
man you are territorial and i think
there's nothing wrong with it because
personally would i want a loads of women
flocking around my man and my man just
being nice for the sake of it no so i
feel like there shouldn't be a problem
you would appreciate it though
you would appreciate it because your
man's valued that that's the only
difference i would say if a lot of women
liked your man in some sense you'll be
like no but i'm saying how he's acting
towards them you see there's a
difference like you see
now if i'm he's at the club there's
loads of women they're all just flirting
with him and
he's kind of being disrespectful to the
point where like you are drawing lines
because if i was to do that or you can't
even let me out to go in the club by
myself but yet you that's just you being
a shitty person but i'm just speaking
for the people who do have clear
intentions and don't necessarily don't
want their girlfriend to go out to the
club because they just have one personal
control it's just about respect and
boundaries and whatever you're
comfortable with you agree to it i
guess yeah i agree i think that was a
really good point
sorry five waffled no no
i understood i understood what you were
saying uh we're going to react to one
more clip um from andrew tate
um blessing do the one
that's
uh andrew tate exposes the truth behind
women cheating
that's the last one we're gonna do not
that one do that one yeah
really involves emotion
you will not sleep with a man you don't
like i can see the woman i don't like
it's completely a different thing i can
be head over heels in love with a woman
ready to die for her ready to take a
bullet for her protector give her all
the money in the world make sure she has
a beautiful family a nice big house all
of it and i'll still
watch me female infidelity involves
emotion
you will not sleep with a man you don't
like i can see the woman i don't like
it's completely a different thing i can
be head over heels in love with a woman
ready to die for her ready to take a
bullet for her protector give her all
the money in the world make sure she has
a beautiful family a nice big house all
of it and i'll still
watch me you know
[Laughter]
this is probably one of the few things i
can't endorse him for even if it's a
it's a fact but again i agree what you
said delivery is everything so to say in
that manner there's no need but it's
true i feel well is he not doing his job
by doing that because his job his job is
to earn more like he's trying to earn
more money and get more views and the
way that he's saying that is gonna it's
funny bring more
it's funny and it's gonna bring
i couldn't help but laugh but then any
dangerous thing about that is planting
things in and you we know this
personally it's as young men
young individuals they pick things up
quickly yeah if they go out in the world
talking and acting like that it's that's
the only danger because they don't
necessarily understand that he's doing
it you know to make more money and
exactly he's exaggerating and it's
almost like i believe it's a pers like a
persona
but yeah i don't know i think he cheats
on his girlfriend oh he probably does
but i think i think he that's what i
mean i think if young men want to strive
to make enough money that they can cheat
like that i think shoot for the stars
man
i think is a headache juggling so many
scenarios but yeah i understand a lot of
men a lot of men wanted to be james bond
they want to be this guy i wouldn't
recommend it you know yeah just like if
you want if you want to go try to be a
multi-million like make 300 plus million
i'll do that bit but i can't have ladies
banging on my door and disrupting me
waking me up that's the bit i don't
fancy either so but i agree i think
women are more attached
when it comes to that and i respect them
a lot more for that but i think
generally a man can love a woman and go
elsewhere do his dirt and come back i
don't know why don't ask me but i think
it's biology
i think that comes back to the men are
built to procreate and that is the
action
probably that yeah that makes it makes a
lot of sense i want to add though like
um you often say like we always forget
to add or let women know you know the
consequences to their actions and all
that i think what he's missing in this
is that you know he's definitely you
know he's 300 million plus all that
he's speaking to an audience of guys
like sometimes i sit there and i listen
to him i'm like hmm i hear it i see it
there's logic there but if i try to pull
that off in my relationship
i'll be left so how do i how do i sit
this girl down and like let her know i
want to do this as well like it just
can't yeah
he should add that element of like
there's consequences to your actions
like this is kind of how i operate these
these are my standards like i can go
pull another 10 off the streets fine but
you probably can't so things he might do
he might expand on it this is just that
one clip no i've watched this whole
thing yeah he doesn't i love this this
is one of my favorite ones because i
think he does such a good job for like
like men on this but
well this one this clip is like an
entertainment yeah you know what i'm
saying like i just i view everything
through an entertainment lens right and
i'm sorry this this is beautiful this is
the most beautiful like inner when i
watched it i died it's so funny it's
almost scripted i love it it's so
perfect
it could be like one of the sketches on
saturday night live type thing like i
feel like it easily could be viewed as
completely just out there and is a joke
yeah i mean that's like yeah
i don't know how many millions of you i
think got over like yeah yeah it's
stupid but but that's where he loses
people right because it's one thing to
just hear it and be like yeah i get it i
get it that makes sense but
eighty percent of the guys out there are
going to be like okay i just got this
girl
but how else would he have reached that
many people if he didn't perfect that
comedy
and that's what i mean like you will
never get the audience if you cannot
entertain captivate and be funny and
that's like
in my opinion like entertainers have
different views on this but like i think
that's
the most important thing yeah yeah he's
a very smart guy like
hearing him speak he just he hit certain
beats and i'm like
your mind is moving quickly i respect it
what do you guys think about this clip
is cheating different for men and for
women
i think i've spoken
um
yeah i do think
yeah i think women do if
yeah
i think women cheat with more emotion i
would say i think
i think it's a hard one i think yeah if
you're talking about a woman cheating
when she's in a relationship i think
yeah there's usually
some what's the saying they say that the
woman has usually left the relationship
mentally before she leaves physically so
i feel like if a woman is cheating it's
probably there isn't another man there
isn't more of an emotional connection
and she's already tapping out of that
relationship whereas i do think like
what kind of wheels just sort of said
like men can kind of
go out cheat and still come home and
love their women and so yeah i
definitely do think there is a bit of a
difference when it comes to cheating
with men and women i think the emotions
behind it are are different do you think
it's cheating if a woman is like
entertaining dms or dm'ing people yeah i
think i would say that's cheesy yeah i
think it's the same if a guy does that
yeah i would say that's cheating yeah
well i still love my lady that was just
a little bit of but personally i
personally i would class i can't explain
it something personally i would class as
cheating is if it's something you
wouldn't do in front of your partner or
let your partner see yeah like so even
if you're just chatting to a girl
but the way that you're talking to her
is a little bit more flirtatious than
you normally would if your girlfriend
was stood there you wouldn't be acting
like that you wouldn't be stood so
closely to her you wouldn't be buying
her a drink no i wouldn't it's
disrespectful don't get me wrong but
i don't like i said for a man he's not
he might not go there he might not even
respect this lady but she's entertaining
himself i think if a woman does it she's
then if they feel that if they feel that
need to be entertained by other women
they're clearly not 100 happy in their
relationship or they don't want to be
committed to someone so therefore they
shouldn't be committed to someone unless
it's an open relationship or something
like that but isn't it an attention
thing like everyone like we like to say
women like attention but i think men
also like attention but one side gets
attention the other side has to seek
attention so if you
just get attention and you're still
seeking attention isn't that something
to be like eh but if you're like you
don't get attention you're seeking
attention can't we like excuse that i'm
curious
so hang on can you wear it another way
like
so
guys by and large don't get attention
like you're not just dm'ing guys just
for the fun of it to like say hi usually
it's the other way around yeah um but
you'll entertain it maybe if you're
single because you enjoy having someone
just talk to you right like someone
cares enough someone likes you enough
giving you attention i mean i i probably
would reply yeah if i was single but
it's really i i was i went from one
long-term relationship to not long
afterwards being in another one for
nearly six years so it's really nice
i'll be the one to target this
yeah it's really hard for me to answer
that question
yeah i get what you're saying and i've
never really thought of it in that sense
but i would still class it as cheating i
i i still would but i it's interesting
because i've never thought about in that
sense about a man still wanting that
attention from outside because he
doesn't necessarily get it whereas a
woman's more likely to get if she was to
just go out and walk down the street for
example
um but i would still personally cast
that sheet and if i was to see that on
my man's phone i wouldn't be happy i
actually like what you said where it's
something you wouldn't do it in front of
your partner i mean i think i do think
cheating's different for men and for
women and like like if a woman does it
it's cut
like what you were saying the
relationship is over yeah where a man
can just cheat and it's nothing yeah but
but the thing is like in average
relationships with normal people you
can't cheat like so many people will say
like oh cheating it has to be something
physical whatever like but personally i
i would feel like if it's something that
i couldn't do in front of my partner
that that was cheating whether that is
like
like an action the way that i'm speaking
to somebody anything like i just i feel
like that would be classic cheating
person yeah do you guys blame
okay so one in four marriages are
sexless
do you blame a man for cheating if his
wife isn't giving him sex
and he doesn't want to put his kid at
every statistical disadvantage because
his other option is to leave right but
like that hurts the kids
or if the husband isn't giving the wife
sex if you think about it i mean has he
has he spoken to her about it yeah and
she said that she's not
yeah this is actually it's funny i i
actually i talked to my mom about this
um because when i found out that said i
was like that's stupid
so that's what i do when i find out fun
facts is i call my family
and i called my mom and she's like yeah
that happens all the time like after a
woman has kids i guess like
um partially her mating strategy is
fulfilled but then part my mom says it's
because like they get the affection from
the kids so they just like don't desire
their husband the same
and you know then in the red pill
they'll say like um it's because she
didn't really like that wasn't her first
choice she just wanted kids so it's
probably a mix of both right but yeah
it's like where they they talk to their
wives about it and they haven't they
classify sexless as if they haven't had
sex i think it's in one to two months
three months maybe it's three months i
don't remember
the thing is i don't know like if if
they're married and they've got kids
like there's so many other things that
are
in their minds going to be
like a priority in life and you know if
you're running around after like three
kids and you've you've got a job and a
like a house to hold down and all of
that you're realistically going to come
home at the end of the day and you're
going to be knackered are you really
going to want to do that it's not that
you're not necessarily attracted to your
partner or you don't want to
but
it's just that you know it could be an
energy thing it could be a time thing
would you say um because men can't say i
don't want to protect and provide why is
it that women can say we don't feel like
having sex because if a burglar comes
into the house and tries to attack us
like they can't say well i don't i don't
feel like protecting you today but i
think i think men and women can both say
i don't feel like having sex i don't
think i mean i don't know
i try to say no before it just doesn't
really run too long
i mean every man in this room can vouch
for me on that
it's not it's not very often a man tells
a woman i don't want sex it's just and
it's okay it's all dandy at the end of
the day yeah it's just facts isn't it
there's usually something
that comes after that or it's like oh
you're what's wrong with you
yeah
you're almost in trouble
and it's sad because it's not even just
in a relationship like if you go out to
the club and some girl's like really on
you and you're not down
you'll be shamed for it but is that
because women assume that men always
want sex because most men when you're
out in clubs or whatever that is what
they're after
probably yeah she yeah you're magical on
that because it's a double it's like
it's uh um you can't have it both ways
because in one sense you're saying you
know is it fine for a man to cheat on
his wife if he's not giving him sex and
that's what i don't i don't think it is
i've never said it but that's the
question that's that's the question yeah
and the only reason we have that
question is because we assume that you
know guys always just want sex it's kind
of part of our natural desire so is it
kind of unfortunate that
when girls just assume like oh yeah he
just always wants sex in like a
situation that's not like
family and then we get the short end of
the stick is that i mean
i feel like he wants sex just not with
you
[Laughter]
victoria's secret model maybe not the
ones today but like you know the classic
one
came up to him like hey hey tell me
what's trying to think of a good you
guys tell me your celebrity crush
i don't even know
michael b jordan
did you say that michael because that's
what's happening
that's a good peg that's it that's a
good pick
but yeah you look like a laura harvey
loki
i wasn't
sorry
is it because i'm mix race
um okay well i think we're gonna close
out the show to late night so um
appreciate you guys staying here and
like bearing with us through all the
tech issues um why don't we go around
everyone say any final thoughts you have
anything you want to speak your piece on
this is actually being recorded because
the live wasn't working so
um no super chat so no roast today
um you could start and then go around
then we'll go back um yeah i enjoyed my
myself on this show i'm getting insight
from strong women and strong men
and uh thank you i thought it was really
interesting to see how we all think
differently about the same things we see
and yeah honestly there hasn't been much
for me to fully disagree on but in
different interpretations always
interesting to see yeah
i think i definitely enjoy speaking to
people like that
like i think the majority of people i
might be wrong i think the majority of
people here are
single i'm not
saying me and you
but everyone else is so like it's
interesting to see like the difference
in opinion between people who are single
and who aren't especially regarding and
andrew tate and everything that he says
thank god i guess
no obviously we we we're a podcast we
kind of like you know do this and talk
about different like relationships and
um you know different topics and stuff
but it's always good to kind of come on
these things and meet new people and get
different um opinions um so yeah no it's
been it's been really great it's been
lovely meeting you all but yeah follow
us the lady hustle podcast
oh
do you wanna you two wanna go oh sorry
she's usually your spokesperson
um
i love differences in opinion i really
do it's good to not be in an echo
chamber and to get curious about where
people come from and to dig a little bit
especially if we disagree a very
um
a very enjoyed disagreement you threw me
some nice curveballs now i'll just relax
yeah definitely this is this is the joy
of debate right so yeah i've definitely
enjoyed it so yeah thank you having us
and find us on baby hustle podcast
you guys go
um this was fun uh thanks for having me
i came all the way from canada i watched
you guys oh i love that thank you wait
you came all the way from canada like
literally i got off the plane like eight
hours a while wait
wait did you come on the show well i
have other reasons to be here but i was
like i might i'm gonna check you out oh
shut up
i was actually good i was thinking no
accent yeah my bad all my boys and girls
are like oh we're gonna check it out
because yeah so um it's been fun thanks
for having me um this was great hearing
everyone's opinions and stuff but i was
hoping like i was praying for like one
of those like hard feminists to come on
and i'll like
have a back and forth
you guys are all pretty like even keel
so
follow me on tech talk fastest lawyer i
need it i need to get that up so come
through
um
i it was interesting today hearing from
different people's perspective and it
actually made me question my own
perspective i feel like as a female now
kind of now seeing a male's perspective
view of how they view things it just
kind of goes to show i think where both
different genders and how we look at
things are different and it's like it
doesn't mean one is less than the other
but it's just about
kind of going about it in a way where
both
like standards or like requirements are
kind of met somehow in the middle like
compromise and i've actually just got
one question now that made me as a
female ask like
you know i feel like we're like i've
seen so much about men this and men do
this but then now i've made like it made
me ask myself as a woman like
do we
set ourselves sometimes unrealistic
standards that men just cannot meet up
to and should we just maybe try to look
at it from a whole point of put like a
bigger picture rather than just from our
mindset as a female
that's really it um
anybody has
stuff
that's like half my podcast
yeah but they can they can answer if
they want real quick um we've totally
discussed this before i'm just gonna say
that we actually do like talking about
this a lot um
yeah elements are true for what you said
but again i think we like the balance of
being able to bet it back because
totally i feel like
wow we could get into this so much but
there are societal standards of like
expectations and disney complex like
right of like what we think and what we
project onto certain relationships
um
preference man preference all comes down
to individual preference and individual
intentions as well in relationships and
intentional dating as well like where
does that come into it
um but yeah we we chopped this off a lot
there's so many episodes where we go too
yeah we're here for like five hours
um it was nice meeting everyone um
my aunt is at vv baby um
this is my first podcast so i just
wanted to say that um
thank you everyone for the experience
and
you know i i love a good debate i would
actually love to hear you ladies content
and yours because i think
you know i came in here thinking like
yeah i'm gonna show something and you
helped me see a different perspective to
things and it's like i love hearing
different arguments because then it
makes you think actually they have a
they kind of have a point there
so i love the podcast
yeah thanks for um coming guys this was
a very fun panel today um you guys are
all very interesting so okay
that's not every panel so
no shade you know anyways um okay guys
don't forget to like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel ring
that notification bell i'm gonna go
through the announcements real quick
um
follow our clips channel um we have two
we have pearl daily and we have just
pearly clips so make sure you follow
both of those um sign up for our
memberships we have the five dollar tier
the ten dollar tier um and then you can
connect with us on social media and and
you get a one-on-one call with me once a
month if you want to sign up for the
fourth tier um it's actually supposed to
be a group call but no one else has
joined so you'd be the first one to be
one-on-one um
my instagram is just dot pearly thing so
go follow that also oh my god i forgot
to say this earlier my tick tock they
took away tick-tock number one they took
away tick-tock number two they took away
tick-tock number three but i am on
tic-tac number for four just pearly
things dot four okay look i'm at let me
let me see how many
four days four days
almost 70k followers look at it every
time they take away an account you guys
get me a new one and you build it up
faster so go follow that i really want
to hit 100k in a week just because i
think it would piss some people off
you can't get rid of me off this app
um member of the week shout out dragon
stallion1001
dm eddie if you want to come on the show
don't forget to subscribe and we will
talk to you next time
bye
[Music]
thank you so much
how is the internet wow
[Music]
foreign
is